for my whole life
[Music]
if I even really existed but I do people
are starting to notes
when you bring me out can you introduce
me as Joker
rated-r welcome back everyone we got a
new Joker trailer and todd phillips the
director talking about future potential
crossover with other batman movies so
we'll break it down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Easter eggs I'll be doing a
bunch more Joker videos Easter eggs and
breakdowns as we get closer to the movie
coming out and their special giveaway
stuff I'll explain at the end of the
video you notice in this trailer and in
the last trailer there Easter eggs for
Thomas Wayne Martha Wayne and Bruce
Wayne in a couple iconic scenes from
notable Batman origin stories you see
them walking out of the theater during
that giant clown riot you see the
Excalibur poster that's right out of
Batman V Superman in Zack Snyder's
version of the Batman origin story where
Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne are
murdered so it's not a spoiler to say
that this is obviously the same little
boy that's probably Bruce Wayne there
was an earlier trailer where you see him
peering through the fence putting a
smile on his little face making it seem
like he's stalking the Wayne's and just
happens to run into young Bruce Wayne so
in the last week there were all kinds of
theory videos that people were posting
about potential for a new origin story
for a new version of the Batman because
we have Robert Pattinson --zz Batman
coming in the next couple of years it's
supposed to be set during the 90s so
people assume you know younger version
of the character if the Joker movie
takes place in the late 70s early 80s
maybe the timeline could work out like
that but there are a lot of questions
because even though the Joker is older
than Batman he's really only like 10
years older than Batman and in the
context of the Joker movie it seems like
the joaquin phoenix version of the
character is almost 30 years older than
this young version of Bruce Wayne so
even though it's really fun to theory
craft if you bend over backwards you
might be able to make it work but the
timeline just doesn't make a whole lot
of sense but this version of the Joker
is just way too old for what you would
need him to be for that version of the
Batman so thankfully the director Todd
Phillips came out at an interview in the
last couple of days and clarified what's
going on with their intentions for this
version of the Joker and potential
future crossover with other Batman
movies following a Heath Ledger's Joker
were you at all reluctant to kind of
revisit this like sacred almost ground
but character
no no I mean I love it and but there was
jared leto followed it and I love that
too and Jack Nicholson preceded it and I
love that it's it's oddly in the States
comic books are our Shakespeare it seems
and you can do many many versions of
Hamlet there will be many more jokers
I'm sure in the future it doesn't work
like that I mean in a movie it happens
in the movie but I mean when you're when
you're directing it's a much slower
thing so it was never it wasn't like an
overnight thing the movie have you seen
the movie yeah no it's cool I disease
because it's a super like slow burn the
transformation isn't like comes out of a
closet like Superman it's it's a sort of
slow transformation that happens no
honestly we just can't believe about the
the Venice thing and we're just coming
off that this is literally the second
time we're showing the movie ever sorry
so just still getting our footing
Joaquin it seems scary good in this
movie it seems like he went super method
did he ever almost take things too far
in your mind where you're like oh whoa
dude like you're getting too dark no and
he doesn't go me he's not method in it
either he really just comes he does the
part we say cut we go over there we
laugh about something he wasn't like
that's not it for this movie that's not
how he had to do it Robert Pattinson was
cast as Batman I know this is a totally
different movie but but do you see those
two worlds merging together anytime soon
no there was a really great clip of him
talking about the movie itself the
character the history of the Joker
character not being afraid of him
referring to comic books as the American
Shakespeare he is a big comic book fan
but Shakespeare gets reinterpreted and
reimagined hundreds of different times
and it doesn't necessarily diminish the
earlier works so he never wrestled with
the legacy aspect of the movie or the
character the stuff he worries about is
mostly practical stuff how good is the
script how are we gonna shoot this scene
how we can handle the release and
promote the movie did the movie we made
convey our thesis on the Joker character
it's a very healthy attitude but I think
a lot of that is just Todd Phillips
himself he's had enough successes as a
director that he's so confident in his
choices that thinking about all the
other versions of the Joker isn't what's
keeping him up at night unless he has
some strange
of clowns that he's not telling us about
but when he says there's no chance for
his version of the joaquin phoenix joker
to cross over with robert pattinson
'he's batman that's this the way he
intended the movie in joaquin phoenix
himself isn't known for doing sequels
remember a couple years ago during that
big Marvel phase three announcement he
was in the running for Doctor Strange
when Marvel wasn't sure whether or not
I'd be able to lock down Benedict
Cumberbatch's the character he turned
them down Joaquin Phoenix said no to
Marvel's Doctor Strange because he did
not want to sign a five or six picture
deal and do a bunch of big franchise
movies so even though the movie is
beginning all kinds of good press and
the first thing that happens when a
comic book movie blows up is that they
try to make a sequel to it it's possible
they could always come back for more but
given what todd phillips has said it
seems more likely that they would just
pick another DC character or batman
villain to do a DC black label style
film for just like this there was
recently some news about Aaron Sorkin
taking a meeting with Warner Brothers
about doing a DC Comics movie so I saw a
lot of people in my timeline going crazy
at the idea that Aaron Sorkin could do
an r-rated Lex Luthor film just like the
Joker that would be a badass backdoor
way to make a new Superman movie you
make it about Lex Luthor and you just
involve Superman in it in a roundabout
way there's no way they're ever gonna do
an r-rated Superman film but you could
do an r-rated Lex Luthor film bryan
cranston has been everybody's fan cast
since way back and batman v superman so
it'll be awesome to see them try
something like that and they're thinking
who could play lex luthor who's bald who
could be menacing walter why the other
interesting things that he talks about
during this interview too are the way
they made the Joker character so you
have Arthur Fleck that's Joaquin Phoenix
through the early parts of the film
eventually he does transform into the
Joker but I love what he's talking to
that interviewer asking about the actual
transformation where you surprised was
this a big deal and he says no no it
wasn't like that the transformation
happens in the movie but it's not like
Superman he doesn't rush into a phone
booth as Arthur Fleck then rushed right
back out as the Joker but talk about
meta Easter eggs if you guys didn't know
there was actually a Superboy TV show
where Joaquin Phoenix played a version
of Superboy
[Music]
it was a show between 1988 and 1992 on
CBS where there was a different villain
in every single episode Joaquin Phoenix
playing the Superboy character the
villain of that episode was called
little Hercules he was trying to blow up
a nuclear submarine in Joaquin Phoenix's
Superboy had to stop him the actual
process for Joaquin Phoenix during the
Joker movie becoming the Joker just took
way longer it was much more drawn-out
and when people talk about this movie as
a more intense perspective driven film
putting you inside the mind of arthur
flick as he's becoming the joker there's
a lot of really tight up shots there's a
lot of long drawn-out scenes where he's
figuring out his makeup and his
mannerisms the things he's going to say
imagine a version of The Dark Knight
where you see Heath Ledger's Joker just
sitting in his room by himself in
between those big action scenes just
putting his makeup on trying to figure
out how things were gonna go looking at
his plans we've never really seen that
with previous versions of the character
so that's one of the big differences
between the Joaquin Phoenix version of
the character and the other Joker's that
have come before interestingly enough he
also reveals that Joaquin Phoenix did
not go method to perform the character
if you're not familiar with acting terms
method acting is when an actor
completely tries to inhabit a role and
literally be that character for the
duration of the shoot 24/7 normally when
actors film scenes they'll break
character the minute they finish filming
a scene
Christian Bale was also another actor
that did not go method when he was
playing the Batman character during the
Dark Knight trilogy when you hear about
people going method to play The Joker
most people are referring to Jared
Leto's version where he literally acted
like the character all the time leading
up into pre-production when they were
actually filming the movie there were
all those stories about him sending
really creepy crazy disgusting gifts to
the other cast members so most actors
are not method just because it's so
intense and if you're trying to go
method for the Joker you literally have
to be crazy like the Joker 24/7 and that
would just mess anybody up so much you
would need to go through so much therapy
after you finish that movie because the
movie is coming out in a couple weeks
there'll be a bunch more trailers
dropping onto Easter egg videos for all
that stuff and talk about the future
of the DC black labels how the Joker
movie is changing the way they make DC
movies so let me know in the comments
what is the next DC character you want
to see get a really intense spin-off
r-rated film we're doing a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
Joker theory on the video
everybody click here for my non-spoilery
joker movie review and click here for
that brand new Rick and Morty season 4
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you